non
la mort tient salon au bourget premier
salon international de l'industrie des
pompes funèbres un chiffre d'affaires
annuel de 13 milliards de francs en
france pour les amoureux des gros et
petits cubes visite complète du salon de
la moto
beyrouth deuxième colis piégés en une
semaine après l'aéroport l'hôpital de
l'université américaine bilan 7 morts et
31 blessés
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
voilà monsieur bonsoir ce n'est pas
notre habitude d'ouvrir le journal par
un salon professionnel aussi intéressant
qu'il soit mais celui ci vaut qu'on
fasse exception à la règle
en effet au bourget près de paris s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui sur plus de vingt
mille mètres carrés
le premier salon international des
pompes funèbres un secteur qui ne
connaît malheureusement pas de crise
pour la france par exemple cela
représente un chiffre d'affaires de 13
milliards par an pour une moyenne de 500
mille décès annuels ce n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que cette industrie se
porte bien mais jusqu'à présent elle
avait dix ont quelques répugnance à sa
fiche question sans doute d'évolution
des mentalités mais dorénavant fini les
tables ce premier salon international
propose toutes les nouveautés et même
les modes en matière de pompes funèbres
patrice pollet c'est ce matin que tout a
commencé
je me suis dit allons faire un tour au
salon de l'art funéraire vingt minutes
plus tard je me retrouve avec l'équipe
asile zag et entre les fleurs les tombes
et les cercueils des six recrues au
capitonnage tout à fait incroyable sont
là les dernières tendances de la mort
sont choisis d'après une étude de marché
toute façon moi je crois à la vie après
la mort alors autant autant y aller de
toute façon avec les meilleures
conditions possibles et finalement
pourquoi pas avec les fronts un peu plus
loin on a expliqué que la pierre tombale
était en pleine révolution
les branches et choisiront donc une
pierre chine et de préférence et non
plus piqueté ça fera toute la différence
avec votre voisin de cimetière et puis
on m'a montré le petit rien qui va
renforcer votre image de marque
un petit portrait c'est mieux sachez le
canon grave et laborieuse nous c'est un
tableau qui se fait à la pointe de taxe
m ce sont des petits points qui se
réunissent les uns aux autres et ses six
petits points en fin de compte qui donne
un relief au portel enfin le portrait du
général de gaulle elle vous a fallu
combien de temps
m'a fallu un peuple un mois et demi et
ça coûte combien une famille pendant le
salon tout le monde a gardé le moral pas
question ici de faire là vous êtes
exposants vous oui je vais exposer avec
des manches l'onu lancé la mode d'un
nouveau gadget
dernière vision juste avant de partir le
top niveau en matière de fabrication
mais décidément les salons ça donne soif
et voir les cercueils
ça donne des idées mais tout n'est pas
du meilleur goût visiblement l'actualité
de ce samedi
c'est d'abord le proche orient après le
sommet arabe d'amman en jordanie
dimanche dernier une à une les nations
arabes renouent leurs relations avec
l'egypte après l'irak les émirats arabes
unis aujourd'hui le maroc
si l'on ajoute à cela la condamnation de
l'iran dans la guerre du golfe par la
quasi unanimité des participants à ce
sommet on trouve là beaucoup de sujets
de mécontentement pour le gouvernement
de terre et cette colère s'exprime
peut-être par liban interposé en effet
après l'attentât de jeudi dernier à
l'aéroport international de beyrouth
un deuxième a eu lieu ce matin à
l'hôpital de l'université américaine à
beyrouth ouest dans la partie musulmane
de la capitale libanaise sous contrôle
direct des six rire bilan 7 morts et 31
blessés
jean-marc il aux sept morts 31 blessés
pour la deuxième fois en trois jours à
beyrouth un engin de mort dans une salle
d'attenté
ce matin seul de l'hôpital de
l'université américaine selon la police
la bombe dissimulée dans une boîte de
chocolat était composée non seulement
d'un kg de tnt d'une grenade 106
mais aussi de cloud objectif apparent
non seulement tu es mais aussi
terrorisée et surtout peut-être défier
la syrie explications ce beyrouth ouest
à majorité musulmane où se vident la
majorité des querelles libanaises et
étrangères
et depuis février dernier sous contrôle
syrien pas de revendication de
l'attentât mais deux hypothèses
peut-être le geste d'extrémistes
chrétiens hostile à la tutelle syrienne
au liban
peut-être aussi celui d' extrémistes
chiites pro iraniens
déjà hostile à la syrie en dépit de son
alliance avec l'iran et rendus furieux
par la participation de la syrie au
sommet arabe
dahmane somme est essentiellement
consacré à la guerre irak iran
or la syrie malgré des réserves a dû
s'associer à une condamnation unanime de
l'iran à la grave encore aux yeux des
pro iranien la série n'aura pu empêcher
que le sommet arabe
on trouvera la porte à l'egypte l'egypte
exclu pour avoir reconnu israël l'egypte
avec laquelle viennent de renouer coup
sur coup les émirats arabes unis l'irak
le maroc et le koweït
téhéran avait estimé que le sommet arabe
ne bénéficiait je cite cas l'usurpateur
sioniste qui ronge syrie israël liban
une fois encore c'est beyrouth qui aura
payé le prix du sang
et puis encore à propos de cette région
le fatah organisations palestiniennes
qui dimanche dernier a enlevé sur un
bateau au large de gaza huit personnes
bénéficiant de la double nationalité
belge française et israélienne
le fatah considère que ces huit
personnes dont deux enfants sont tous
des juifs impliqué dans le mouvement
sioniste en conséquence le fatah prend
contact avec la croix rouge
internationale pour que ces otages soit
transporté dans un endroit sûr d'après
ce communiqué et un délégué de la croix
rouge sera également invité à visiter
ses huit otages
et puis à beyrouth encore le français
qui a été grièvement blessée de trois
balles dans la tête jeudi dernier et ce
soir dans un état désespéré
le 23 octobre 1986 jean bedel bokassa a
été condamné à mort par le tribunal de
banque
son pourvoi en cassation vient d'être
rejeté aujourd'hui il ne lui reste plus
donc qu'à attendre la grâce éventuelle
du président centrafricain le général
kolingba y joue l'ex empereur jean bedel
bokassa sera-t-il vraiment exécuter sa
vie dépend aujourd'hui de la seule grâce
de l'actuel chef de l'état centrafricain
général andré kolingba condamné par
contumace à la peine capitale peu après
son renversement en 1979
bokassa vécu puisque en 86 un exil
tranquille en france et puis coup de
théâtre en octobre de la même année il
rentre de son plein gré à l'improviste
en centrafrique sans doute persuadés
qu'ils seraient reçus là-bas bras
ouverts au lieu de cela bokassa est
arrêté à sa descente d'avion incarcéré
puis jugé le souverain ni alors tous les
chefs d'accusation qui sont portées
contre lui
assassinats d'enfants recel de cadavre
anthropophagie
au fond de bataille où l'état a répondu
à la juge mais il y la justice de son
pays vient de rejeter le pourvoi en
cassation de bokassa contre l'arrêt de
la cour criminelle de bangui le
condamnant à mort sept four n'a pas
accepté les arguments de la défense
selon laquelle ce tribunal de droit
commun était incompétent pour juger l'ex
empereur centrafricain sauf grâce
exceptionnelle
rien ne s'oppose donc plus à l'exécution
de la sentence au niger après le décès
du président kountché la semaine
dernière à paris c'est un colonel qui
est nommé chef de l'état le colonel ali
said nouvelle calédonie les positions se
durcissent l'union calédonienne
composante principale du fln ks le
mouvement indépendantiste prône ce
qu'elle appelle la résistance à
l'occupation française notamment dans
les cas où la gendarmerie tenterait
d'appréhender un mélanésiens et cela
pour quelques motifs que ce soit et le
son côté le rpcr anti-indépendantistes
lui considère comme une véritable
incitation au meurtre
les déclarations de jean marie tjibaou
président du fln k s qui a évoqué les
traîtres et les collabos kanak servant
d'un formateur à la police pas de pitié
pour ces gens là at il déclaré tout en
affirmant qu'il n'était pas question de
les supprimer disons physiquement en
polynésie française les dockers du port
de papeete à l'origine des émeutes du 23
octobre dernier ont décidé de suspendre
leur grève et de reprendre le travail
sans pour autant que leurs
revendications étaient satisfaites
affaires lüscher la vente d'armes
clandestine à l'iran aurait continué
après l'arrivée de monsieur chirac à
l'hôtel matignon 86 via l'espagne cette
fois ci cette information du quotidien
espagnol el país et démentie par la
direction des douanes françaises
indiquant qu'aucun des bateaux concernés
n'avaient embarqué de matériel de guerre
à l'escale de cherbourg et contrairement
à ce que j'avais indiqué par erreur dans
le journal de 13h le journal el país n'a
pas d'appartenance politique c'est un
journal indépendant dont acte le
magazine le point lui publie cette
semaine deux photos de la cargaison du
navire panaméen arraisonné par les
douanes françaises au large des côtes
bretonnes
à une quinzaine de jours sur les deux
photos non signé on peut distinguer les
mots tripoli et libya ce qui tendrait à
accréditer la thèse d'une cargaison en
provenance de libye à destination des
terroristes de l'ira en irlande la libye
dément formellement être impliqué dans
ce trafic
les déclarations de jacques delors
affirmant qu'ils ne refuserait pas le
poste de premier ministre de monsieur
raymond barre si celui ci bénéficie
d'une large majorité à l'élection
présidentielle continue de susciter des
réactions surtout dans l'opposition le
candidat communiste andré lajoinie
s'exclame je trouve cela un peu fort
le socialiste georges sarre demande que
jacques delors soit condamné avec force
et monsieur me roy s'est exprimé cet
après midi à lille écoutons le
pourquoi les déclarations ici ou là
maladroite incompréhensible inadaptée au
contexte actuel
pourquoi des interrogations sur la ligne
du parti socialisme pourquoi chercher
dans un brouillard artificiel manquerez
des accommodements va signer complices
entre une droite qui est en très graves
difficultés de gauche et dans les salons
n'existerait plus monsieur bart il
restait six sauts son banc l'assemblée
nationale il les tient entièrement
solidaire de ce que fait monsieur chirac
il a l'air de dire moi moi moi moi
où suis-je milite avec une souche virale
et solidaire de ce gouvernement
j'aurais tendance à le critiquer encore
davantage puisqu'ils n'en est rien eglee
l'accès
la politique de monsieur girard 24
heures après la fin de la mutinerie de
la prise d'otage de la prison de saint
maur dans l'indre c'est l'heure du
premier bilan matériel 100 millions de
francs de dégâts
gérard beaufils près des deux tiers des
432 détenus de sa mort ont dormi cette
nuit dans les locaux saccagés de leurs
centrales
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a pas
pu reloger tout le monde
quelques dizaines de cellules cependant
été épargné par la tornade de colère qui
a soufflé à châteauroux pendant plus de
dix heures
si les prisonniers les plus dangereux
comme georges ibrahim abdallah par
exemple le chef présumé des fractions
armées révolutionnaires libanaises ont
été transférés dans des prisons plus
sécuritaire les autres détenus devront
désormais s'accommoder de leurs
bâtiments dévastés et incendié pendant
la mutinerie
les ateliers de fabrication de meubles
n'existe plus le foyer et le gymnase ont
été détruits partout des morceaux de
tôle des fils électriques et des débris
de verre jonchent le sol
à l'extérieur une partie de l'important
dispositif policier mis en place pendant
les événements a été maintenu pour
prévenir toute tentative d'évasion
certes les portes de la prison ont volé
en éclats lors de l'évasion de trois
détenus mardi dernier mais depuis hier
les révoltés de sa mort ont été placés
sous haute surveillance
al'approche de l'hiver l'organisation
humanitaire médecins du monde a décidé
d'ouvrir à paris un deuxième centre de
consultation destinée à accueillir tous
ceux qui ne bénéficie plus d'aucune
sorte de couverture sociale très autres
centres sont installés dans les
principales villes françaises
roland sicard ils sont en france près
d'un million chômeurs en fin de droits
sans ressources il ne bénéficie d'aucune
protection sociale ils n'ont même pas
les moyens de se soigner
pourtant beaucoup d'entre eux ont connu
une existence normale
la feuille de paie en fin de mois les
formulaires de sécurité sociale le
médecin de famille et puis petit à petit
ils sont tombés dans l'engrenage de m
lorsqu'on a un problème avec l'emploi
chômeurs en fin de droits jeunes en
recherche du premier emploi
eh bien on a une difficulté à produire
des justificatifs ans qu'en plus on a un
problème avec le logement et bien alors
là la protection sociale la sécurité
sociale bloc
bien sûr il ya des aides qui peuvent
être fournis mais au prix d'un combat
administratif un combat où il faut
produire des tas de justificatifs qui
fait que quand on est malade
désespéré voire à la rue eh bien on
renonce dans les centres de soins de
médecins du monde pas besoin de
justificatifs les traitements sont
gratuits les 700 médecins infirmiers
assistantes sociales sont tous bénévoles
700 bénévoles pour 1 millions d'exclus
du système de protection sociale oui
pour illustrer leurs campagnes de
sensibilisation de l'opinion publique
française et bien médecins du monde a
réalisé ce très court document regarde
on ce pays ils sont près d'un million ne
pas pouvoir se faire soigner comme les
autres
dans ce pays il souffre de solitude et
le silence
le chômage de tolérance
ce pays
c'est la france
ici là bas médecins du monde à l'issue
des deux journées d'états généraux de la
sécurité sociale jeudi et vendredi
dernier le ministre des affaires
sociales philippe seguin annonce que des
mesures seront prises reste à savoir
lesquels et combien en tout cas
l'unanimité c'est au moins fait sur un
point une taxation plus forte de
l'alcool et du tabac
l'un des hommes les plus riches du monde
au secours d'un secteur de l'industrie
française en difficulté les manufacture
de tapis d'aubusson
c'est notre bon point un peu spéciale de
ce soit en effet le sultan de brunei un
minuscule état de la côte ouest de
bornéo a commandé à la savonnerie robert
four d'aubusson une oeuvre sans doute la
plus importante du siècle au moins par
sa taille puisqu'elle mesure 13 mètres
de long sur 7 de là je suis patrick
boitet philippe menut
les petites mains se sont mises à 12 15
heures par jour pendant cinq mois pour
fabriquer le plus grand tapis de
savonnerie du siècle surface 91 mètres
carrés soit une demi tonne le prix n'est
pas encore défini entre un million et
demi et deux millions de francs mais
l'acquéreur est naturellement étrangers
il sent qu'il n'y ait plus assez de
famille suffisamment fortunés pour
acheter de telles pièces en france dont
vous êtes obligés d'exporter autres
productions 1 on exploite à peu près 95%
votre chose ironie du sort la
manufacture robert pourra relancer l
activité parce que contrainte et forcée
du fait de la baisse de commandes dans
son secteur traditionnel la tapisserie
depuis cinq ans en effet toute la région
d'aubusson est touché par une grave
récession les clients traditionnels se
font rares et les nouvelles générations
bout de la tapisserie trop cher ou
passés de mode à l'école des arts
décoratifs d'aubusson
on ne forme plus eu 15 vicié
professionnelle par promotion un choix
volontaire c'est largement suffisant
étant donné qu'au mieux ne pas former de
chômeurs certaines manufactures ferme
on ne compte plus que 150 lycée
professionnel dix fois moins qu'au début
du siècle
les seuls qui s'en sortent sont ceux qui
s'adapte au marché la fabrication de
tapis de savonnerie
longtemps considérée comme un art mineur
à aubusson comparé aux tapisseries
d'essence plus artistique pourrait être
la solution
c'est bon et est-ce qu'à terme ce n'est
pas condamné l'activité tracts ciel de
puissance à voir la tabbee c'est bien le
contraire je pense que la savonnerie
nous permettra de combler les creux de
charge la télé que nous pouvons avoir
et en même temps elle subventionnera le
maintien dans cette profession des
lissiers de très haute qualité qu'on
appelle les faiseurs de chair qu'il faut
absolument maintenir cette profession
dans une conjoncture difficile
robert four a réussi à conserver son
personnel à ceux qui voudraient mettre
en cause la qualité artistique de sa
production
il n'a qu'une question à poser 10 il est
pas joli mon papy
oui pour étaler ma culture j'ajouterai
que si l'on parle de savonnerie pour les
manufactures de tapisserie d'aubusson
c'est que souvent les 4 ces entreprises
ont été installé dans d'anciens locaux
de fabrique de savon se tapit
destination du sultanat de bruneï comme
viens de vous le dire patrick groulx
était sera exposée à l'hôtel des
invalides à paris du 20 au 22 novembre
en argentine arrestation d'un ancien
criminel de guerre nazi réclamé par les
tribunaux d'allemagne fédérale joseph
léo choir mme berg heure ancien ss est
accusé de génocide contre des juifs
polonais pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est pour un reportage sur un autre
criminel de guerre nazi klaus barbie et
sa seconde vie en amérique du sud qu'un
grand porteur d'antenne 2 daniel leconte
a reçu le prix honda ce prix du meilleur
reportage européen daniel leconte et ce
soir sur notre plateau avec l'objet de
valeur qu'il a reçus à l'occasion du duo
l'occasion de cette remise de prix alors
daniel nous n'avons pas souvent
l'habitude de parler du travail de grand
reporter ici nous faisons nous n'en
parlons pas en nous le montrons mais on
peut peut-être le faire ce soir c'est un
hommage que nous vous rendons et
attraper à tous les reporters à travers
vous on ne se rend pas toujours très
bien compte du temps qu'il faut pour
arriver pour mettre sur pied un
reportage et là on en a la consécration
alors c'est pas avoue daniel que je vais
apprendre cela puisque vous même vous
avez très grand reporter pour cette
raison l'effectuons pour les
téléspectateurs c'est peut être
intéressant de savoir sur un reportage
de 52 minutes le temps qu'il faut pour
arriver à ce résultat
alors entre le moment entre le début de
mon enquête et le produit fini celui qui
est passé à l'antenne il s'est passé un
peu plus d'un an un an pourquoi un an
parce qu'il y avait plus de 40 ans 40
années d'histoire contemporaine à
maîtriser parce qu'il y avait 2000 pages
d'un gros dossiers que j'ai trouvé en
arrivant j'ai trouvé pas par hasard
évidemment en enquêtant sur place et et
cinq semaines de tournage donc sur place
dans des conditions un peu difficiles
parce que vous imaginez bien que tourné
en bolivie
au pérou c'est pas comme tournée en
europe quand nous sommes arrivés là-bas
et bien il y avait pour rendre un peu
compte de la situation dans laquelle
nous avons travaillé
l'inflation de ce pays était à 3000%
elle est passé ensuite dans l'est dans
les mois qui ont suivi à 10 mille pour
cent
il y avait trois semaines de grève
générale avec des mineurs qui défilaient
dans les rues de la ville et des
barrages de paysans sur les routes donc
des conditions de travail très
difficiles qui sont les conditions en
fait que tous les reporters d'antenne 2
est d'ailleurs rencontre quand ils sont
sur leurs lieux de tournage bien alors
la deuxième chose qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est que on nous reproche souvent de
trains petit peu rapide dans nos
conclusions de parfois frôler avec de se
frotter à la vérité mais nous comme nous
sommes les historiens de limay de
l'immédiat nous avons le droit à
l'erreur ce rallye nous faisons très
attention cris dans cette affaire vous
avez fait très adapté forcément il
fallait faire très attention parce qu'il
y avait beaucoup de documents nous
savions qu'elle et être épluchés c'était
une affaire qui était sous sous les feux
de la rampe j'allais dire avec un procès
au bout donc il a fallu consulter des
archives et être sur des éléments que
nous avancions et c'est à cette
condition seulement qu'on pouvait
arriver à ce résultat alors j'en profite
en même temps pour remercier tous les
gens qui ont travaillé avec moi sur ce
reportage parce que c'est une équipe une
équipe qui a fait son travail qu'il a
très bien fait c'est à elle aussi que ce
prix est la leur si vous voulez bien
dernière je vais les cités pour terminer
cette équipe qui a travaillé sur ce
reportage et qui reçoit ce prix en même
temps que vous pour le montage c'était
virginie walbaum le caméraman c'était
pascal puyoô leçon richard de la fuente
et l'assistant jean bernard conte pour
les fanas de motos ouverture de leur
salon à la porte de versailles c'était
aujourd'hui thierry blancot
le salon de la moto on y rêve de plus en
plus jeunes devant ces vrais le look
plutôt futuriste des machines car ce qui
est en train de changer au fond c'est
peut-être ça le look du motard et celui
des motos forme aérodynamique
équipements tendance fluo gros efforts
sur le design en profondeur c'est un
look africain maintenant d'où toutes les
motos les trail sont habillés comme des
reines de l'afrique avec des gros
réservoir des boca rénale c'est de ce
label moto
des belles motos bonne à tout faire
pratiquer en ville utile à la campagne
moyenne cylindrée
voilà le prototype de la machine la plus
vendue un air de paris dakar et à défaut
des pistes africaines l'évasion sur les
boulevards avec en prime une solution à
tous les problèmes de stationnement il
en ces temps nouveaux cadeaux de noël
beaucoup moins gros mais en pleine
expansion le scooter problème
la cible est essentiellement urbaine
mais le marché se développe avec
paraît-il une très forte clientèle
féminine sensible elle aussi aux
couleurs et aux formes la mode toujours
la mode sont des design très très pur
créneau bo qui sont renouvelés en
permanence on parle de prix bien sûr
parce que le prix est très important
surtout pour les jeunes
mais c'est essentiellement la mode qui
fait le scooter et le scooter pic à la
mode
moto scooter vous serez assurément des
milliers à rêver cette semaine devant
ces monstres et de toute façon si vous
n'avez pas les moyens il existe aussi ce
modèle est pour le vol il ya moins de
risques tennis demi finales du tournoi
de wembley henri leconte affronter ivan
lendl trop fort lendl pour le compte le
compte a été battue 2 sets à 0
quant à yannick noah victime d'une
déchirure abdominale à l'occasion de
l'open de paris vous l'avez sans doute
vu sur antenne 2 eh bien il a décidé de
se soigner en conséquence il ne
réapparaîtra pas sur les courts de
tennis avant le début de l'année janvier
à l'occasion des internationaux
d'australie puis enfin forfait en
football du capitaine de l'équipe de
france luis fernandez pour le match
france-eire des à mercredi prochain à
paris il sera remplacé par le toulonnais
bernard pardo
demain le tiercé des obstacles d'auteuil
ne réunira que dit partant celui de
dimanche dernier n'en comptait que 12
c'est peu c'est trop peu et cet état de
fait il y à cet état de fait il y a
plusieurs causes plusieurs raisons
pierrette brès ces chevaux sont à peine
trois ans il manque de métier
d'endurance
la fatigue se fait sentir en fin de
parcours mais il faut bien qu'ils
courent pour apprendre à 5 ans ils
savent sauter mais cela n'empêche pas
les chutes
la sélection est très dur et les vieux
soit d'obstacles se feront de plus en
plus rares le terrain lourd et la
difficulté des obstacles ne sont pas des
raisons suffisantes pour expliquer le
manque de chance le yoga simple c'est
que la qualité des chevaux d'obstacle a
consciemment diminué ces dernières
années on a des chevaux de moins en
moins bon et la politique actuellement
le handicapeur c'est nier le droit au
brouhaha les handicaps donc tous les
choix qui sont en bas du tableau aucune
espèce de chance alors on court pas il
faudrait remonter l'échelle des poids et
condamner les bons chevaux que les bons
chevaux puissent macway les gros
handicaps
mais si les partants se sont rares c'est
peut-être aussi la faute des
propriétaires qui n'ont ni les moyens ni
la patience de ménager leurs jeunes
chevaux ont pour attendre des chevaux ça
coûte cher
bon il ya de moins en moins d'argent
dans le circuit des courses puisque
l'état en prend de plus en plus alors
nous sommes actuellement une institution
nous sommes une industrie qui est
asphyxié il y va de ceux de ses courses
de ce magnifique programme d'obstacles à
la française qui est unique au monde et
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à le
maintenir
si on n'arrive pas à maintenir un
effectif de chevaux et de cavaliers qui
puisse courir ces épreuves là nous
perdrons une richesse qui est vraiment
une richesse nationale
et j'ajouterai que ça se complique
probablement aussi d'un problème d'homme
parce que dans des enquêtes que nous
faisons nous nous apercevons que bien
des propriétaires ou des entraîneurs
pourraient aligner deux chevaux et ne le
font pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
montrent qu'ils aiment pour relancer
l'intérêt de ces courses on pourrait
raccourcir les distances à baisser les
obstacles et faire d'auteuil en
hippodrome accessible aux chevaux
étrangers
le signal d'alarmé tiré mais auteuil
préserve jalousement sa spécialité pour
sauter restons français et moi je
sautais un dernier obstacle de ce
journal c'est ce sont les résultats du
tiercé d'aujourd'hui que vous allez voir
s'inscrire sur votre écran lui 13 22 et
puis le quarté + nom n'y avait que le
tiercé aujourd'hui bien je me suis un
petit peu avancé pirette les pronostics
de demain oui exactement alors vous
l'avez vu il y aura pas beaucoup de
partants demain après-midi dans le prix
maurice gillois dit shero seulement le
numéro saint-just car je vous le
rappelle a été déclaré forfait alors 6
10 une ces dix concurrents représentent
l'élite et les meilleurs spécialistes
estiment chaises et ne vont faire preuve
à la fois l'adresse de courage et de
ténacité pour arriver au bout de ces
quatre mille quatre cents mètres dans un
terrain aussi pénible bref c'est une
affaire de spécialistes encore une fois
et c'est le choix que j'ai fait dans le
pronostic que je vous propose maintenant
avec en tête 4 co le numéro 1 collins le
numéro 2
ken wills 4 pagani
3b lot numéro 6 et pour terminer rubika
le numéro 8
je répète leur numéro 1 2 4 3 6 et 8
après les pronostics les prévisions
météo sophis il ya un dimanche pluvieux
en perspective mais la nouvelle
importante c'est que les vents se
remettent à souffler et cela dès cette
nuit
ils souffleront de mains très fort
surtout sur les côtes 120
kilomètres/heure 70 km heure à
l'intérieur du pays
alors une perturbation traverse la
france d'ouest en est résultat à la mi
journée et bien des nuages et de la
pluie sur la vendée la bretagne et côtes
du nord l'ile-de-france donc sur toutes
ces régions des nuages des nuages qui
vont progresser pour gagner l'est du
pays en cours de journée des chutes de
neige sur les alpes à partir de 1500 m
et des gelées demain matin sur le
nord-est
seul le pourtour méditerranéen connaîtra
quelques éclaircies et des températures
qui remonte un petit peu à l'ouest mais
qui resteront fraîches à au nord-est de
8 degrés donc en alsace jusqu'à 14 14 à
nantes et de 10 à limoges à lyon jusqu'à
20 degrés en corse demain nous serons le
dimanche 15 novembre une fêteront les
albères voilà pour les albert et puis
pour les autres aussi ce soir spécial
champs elysées consacré à thierry le
luron avec la diffusion d'un spectacle
exclusif le luron en liberté au gymnase
c'était son dernier spectacle et puis
ensuite en fin de programme
rendez vous avec philippe gassot sur ce
plateau philippe gassot qui veillent
pour vous au revoir bonsoir excellente
soirée à demain midi